all right luna moon
luna moon uh tell me where you're from
originally where do you grow up i'm from
san francisco california i'm from
oakdale and tell me about your your
family growing up you had mom and dad
yes i grew up with my mom
got moved to my grandmother's house
raised in the oakdale projects
how would you describe your childhood
my childhood was
interesting
it was
i didn't really struggle much
but
i
i've always been like an introvert
solo by myself
but i have a very big family
where was your dad
my dad was on drugs
down in the san francisco tenderloin
but his family was very supportive
his family's great
so sounds like a fairly good childhood
it was okay
no abuse no crazy stuff like that
yes i was sexually abused from the time
i was four up until
i guess when you didn't no longer chaos
it's called sexual abuse oh jesus really
so yeah that's a long time
yeah i still talked to the guy who
molested me
i still love him
wow yeah that's interesting
yeah it is but
it's how you know i'm used to it did it
become like normalized it did i thought
it was my boyfriend
from four years old yeah first time i
slept his dick i didn't know what that
meant you know because he kept saying
kiss it and so what i did was i went
you know
but i caught on pretty quickly after
that
yeah
or like the first time he tried to stick
his finger in my little coochie it
wouldn't go in because it was just you
know i don't think
anything's supposed to go in there at
that time four years old yeah but you
know eventually as i got bigger we
figured it out
how old was he
he was seven years older than me so he
was young
wow
you didn't tell anybody
no he said it was a secret sure
when i did tell friends when i got to
like middle school about my boyfriend
and us having sex you know they told
their moms and um
then
i remember being confronted by a large
group of people his mom was like come
outside you know you said my son you
know raped you and i was like no and she
had him with her and then i looked in
his eyes and you know i knew you know uh
oh
you know
this you know you're not my boyfriend
we weren't supposed to be doing this at
all yeah
so i just said no you know and then we
just continued in secret
you protected him
yeah yeah
i love you yeah i think that that's a
common
it's not that's how it often happens i
think
you you actually fall in love with the
person who's doing this to you right
yeah
and then uh tell me about what kind of
kid were you in high school
in high school i went to several
different high schools i went to
juvenile
and youth authority
um
were so assaulting other girls and
starting gangs and things like that
and then when i got to high school i
ended up graduating from downtown high
school it's a continuation school
but i graduated early i had lots of
extra credits i used to literally cut
school to go to the library and read wow
so backwards right you're a good student
i was i graduated with a 4.0 actually
that's great
and did you
pursue anything other than i did this
i'm a licensed esthetician and i also
have a certificate in accounting
right
i know
interesting now you're working the track
i worked the track and
sometimes i like graduated from there
to to like internet stuff yes to online
escorts and sugar daddies sugar days yes
so you started right what age roughly
i started walking on international
and shot well poke
those are blades in san francisco or
tracks in san francisco
and oakland
and then you know
i met other guys other pimps
who put me to the internet
and that's where the money is
the big money that this started for you
at roughly what age
i started dancing at showgirls and the
husker club downtown san francisco when
i was 18. and then
after that i started meeting pimps while
working there
and then i started walking the blade
and
they told me about the internet and i
came up from there
does working at a strip club kind of
work as a
a way to uh work as a prostitute yes
it's like a gateway to prostitution but
more than a gateway it's it's
you know when you're when you're working
at a club there's back rooms there's
guys
you know asking for your phone number
there's opportunities to do more than
just yeah big business in the club and
you make about 600 an hour doing vips in
the club so those guys they'll pay you
1000 and up outside of the club if you
meet them after
but the clubs i worked at you couldn't
really have sex there there are topless
clubs so security's really tight there's
cameras everywhere if a guy even touches
you they come rushing in yeah but
there's nothing against nothing stopping
you from giving out your phone number
nothing nothing at all
and uh
you've had pimps before
yes
do you certainly currently have a pimp
yes
i won't get anybody in trouble so i
won't ask who and
all the details but but that arrangement
works for you it does
you're giving him all your money of
course
and he takes good care of me he takes
good care of you yes
me and my kids you and your kids how
many kids you have i have three sons
and you're raising them of course
i'm a great mom you're a great mom yeah
that's great to hear the contrast
i i've done so many of these interviews
with girls working doing this kind of
work and i rarely hear somebody say i'm
a great mom
yeah i'm a great mom i love my boys
sometimes i might have to miss out but
they come first that's why i do it
that's why you do it oh yeah
oh yeah
i want to see them be great i want them
to have everything they want
how old are you boys
four
seven
in my 10 year old's about to be 11.
cool and the the father is
in their life or
are you no you're raising them it's just
me raising them
when their father comes around it's like
super random but i never deny them you
know that's between though
you know them
and tell me about the uh
the tricks the jobs that
are your customers
do you respect them do you like them
sometimes i like them
personality wise but
you know of course i don't want to be
sexual with them i just want the money
i want to get the money and leave yeah
there's no romance
in it from your side of that
on my side of it there's plenty of
romance i like to think of myself as an
experience
so it's beyond sex
they're feeling down
i'll be whatever they want me to be
i'll be a little girl i'll be a
therapist i'll be a mommy
anything they want
they can customize their experience with
me
and i'll accommodate them accordingly
it's like you're a therapist for them
in a way a sexual therapist
yes
you have a lot of regulars i assume i do
and i like them
but i also know you know
they're temporary they'll go away you
know they know what i do they know what
it is they ordered me offline
you get some some of your clients
kind of getting attached to you falling
in love with you
yes sometimes they do one guy did
and he started every time i would post
my ad he would call me and be really
upset because he had me on allowance
and he wanted me specifically just for
him
but
i portrayed that i was but that's my job
to be a fantasy
to be what he wanted me to be
and once i leave
once i get paid that's it
i'm gone
did your family
know that you were doing this when you
were younger
i believe they knew
no one said anything though
just like when i used to get molested
yeah
no one said anything but what about now
now recently
one of my family was in law enforcement
and they came to me and they said hey
there's pictures of you
on international
so
i stopped going there
so where's probably
it's probably a little thing that some
of your family knows
yeah
but now you know i don't care
they're not paying me
right
yeah if you have bad experiences
oh yeah i've had plenty bad experiences
i just had a recently i just had a bad
experience what kind of stuff happens
um
i signed up for or someone requested a
daddy daughter experience
where i was going to be the little girl
and everything and
you know he started choking me a little
too hard slapping me around you know
couldn't breathe
but he would let go
and i just
inhale
and i just took it you know because i'm
a woman the pimp can't come in with you
right they say they're for protection
but at the end of the day what are they
going to do they're not going to catch a
fed case coming to save you you're by
yourself you know
they're more like personal assistants in
a way
post my ads when i'm too tired transport
me
you know
feed me
be an accountant for me in a sense so i
don't [ __ ] up my bag
yeah
exactly but if i die in there how are
they going to know they might think i
just got extra time
no one would know
no one can save you so you just have to
relax and you can have a phone that
that's like
how you gonna get to your phone if your
[ __ ] naked spread out on the bed and
the grown man is on top of you choking
you and hitting you
what are you gonna do can't get to your
knife you can't get to your gun you
can't get to your phone you got to take
that
do you carry a gun or a knife
of course
no mace
knives are preferable because you know
it's in your hand like if you take out a
gun on a grown man you know
he's and you don't just shoot it right
away he's likely to overpower you take
it and kill you same with the knife so
i'd rather just take it if
i'll just take it
take the pain
hopefully i get out of there hopefully i
don't die
what's your favorite kind of trick
i like sugar daddies i like being on
allowance
because they're so busy
it's not that they can't get a girl it's
just that they don't have the time
you know and they want someone to leave
they don't want you know these women
sticking around they want somebody who's
actually just gonna
you know leave no hassle no stress
take you shopping or deposit money
you go when they call you how much money
will they spend on you
the most i've ever had was a ten
thousand dollar a month
allowance and i saw him
sometimes a week ago by and i didn't see
him sometimes he'd call me you know two
to three times a week to come over
we chill he'd make dinner it's like a
boyfriend girlfriend type of
relationship
he knew my kids i knew his
he thought i was his girlfriend like for
real felt like i was but
he's no one i was attracted to no one i
would have actually
you know been interested in
did he understand that you were seeing
other men
he did but when he acts of course i'd
say no i don't want to break the fantasy
yeah
what's the hardest part of this kind of
work for you
the sex
having sex with somebody letting
somebody into my body that i don't
want
it's disgusting
nasty makes my stomach curl sometimes
after i go throw up
yeah really yeah i don't like it at all
the sex they're touching me the wanting
to kiss me i don't let them kiss me in
my mouth
they try a lot
yeah
i don't like it
i just like the money i'll do whatever
for the money yeah
i appreciate your honesty
no it's like it's just you know
you're telling it like it is
yeah you know what you've been involved
before
yeah i've been in love before
i'm in love right now oh good for you
yeah
how does it how does it happen i mean i
understand there are many different
lifestyles and and your lifestyle is
very different than mine so
you could probably meet somebody who
understands
and accepts your lifestyle
you know
most of my pimps they become my my
boyfriends
and then
it goes from understanding to you know
i don't know it's like you knew i was a
[ __ ] before you fell in love with me
and just as the
trick needs to accept that you might
have multiple guys you're dating
you need to accept that your pimp
probably has multiple girls that he's
having relationships with
yes but i think of them as like
teammates
and what ends up happening is i never
leave i get dismissed
it's kind of like a polygamous
relationship
no no no because usually we don't like
each other we're jealous of each other
yeah oh yeah even though you know i'm a
great team player because together
everyone achieves more
however everyone doesn't see it like
that
they like to compete with me
you know
i get jealous too
i get very jealous
but
they don't know how to hide it
a lot of them lack professionalism
a lot of them are love motivated not
money motivated i'm money motivated so
jealous or not
i'll sleep on it
they may ask you how old you are
no
how many did you ever have dreams of
doing something else with your life when
you were younger yeah i wanted to be a
chemist and i wanted to be or i wanted
to be a librarian i really wanted to be
a librarian
i love books
my favorites catcher in the rye
you're still young you can do it if you
if you get out of the game one day
oh i'll get out but i'm not interested
in pursuing anything education wise i
want a store
i'd rather have a store be a business
owner
so do you have money that you're saving
from doing this kind of work no
you don't have a bank account with a
bunch of money in it no if he spends it
all then i'm [ __ ]
if i say hey i need this and he's
already spent it it's nothing i can do
because i've talked to so many girls who
ended their relationship you know
however from their pimps
and they were left with nothing
yeah that just recently happened to me
my last pimp died
and i lost everything
how would you define success
success
you know
success is obtaining the goals that you
set out for yourself
it's never ending though
can always have more success
there's no cap on it
but for me success looks like
having my business
basically on autopilot
having my sons you know
educated and seeing that they're all set
up you know doing whatever they want to
do being happy young people
and
having a [ __ ] ton of money
all that's
from me you know that i didn't give away
but i always give it away i give
everything away
you think you're addicted to this
lifestyle i am
it's an addiction yeah i'm addicted to
love
and if this is what he wants me to do
then that's what i'm going to do
what was the best example of a loving
relationship you ever saw when you were
young
i don't think i have an example i don't
know what that looks like really
i'm not sure
[Music]
is this a lonely life
it's very lonely
because in a way i'm like the trick
with the pimp you know here i am giving
all of this because i want some kind of
affection
but you know
i'm at the grand master
and he put things into perspective for
me he's great very knowledgeable
yeah he broke it down for me in a way
you know
it's all about the bag
you know
you took away the emotions you're the
first woman first
sex worker i've interviewed who's
compared
the trick you know your your position
with your pimp to the tricks position
with with you but isn't it like that
yeah no i think that's that's a very
insightful way of
interesting analogy absolutely yeah i
know it hit me you just when you when
you first started talking about it about
it five minutes ago and it's very very
true
yeah
you know we pay for them to love us to
pay attention to us
are you making compromises that you're
not totally comfortable with of course
just like when the other women come
or you know just like when
you have to give away all your money
after you went through so much
imagine getting raped and beat
you know and then
saying here you go do you have a quota
with my last pimp i did
what was that quota a thousand dollars a
night
how many nights a week where'd you work
seven
non-stop
rain or shine whatever rain sleet snow
i'm going home
all right i got to go you know you
travel
yes i do travel differently i'm
traveling now
so like you'll go to figaro street in
l.a or you go to la yeah i won't go
there
you know nobody but you go to
like what cities will you now i won't
walk
i'll go you know internet where wherever
the internet takes me
i have stamps in my passport
definitely is the game getting
more lucrative less lucrative more
competitive
you know
people say you know it's competitive
whatever but you got to remember it's
about preference if he likes you
he'll buy you
and you know depending on how you
present yourself
you can either make a hundred dollars on
the street
or
forty dollars on the street or you could
make ten thousand dollars
it's all about how you present yourself
does this
undermine your self-worth your
self-esteem or does it build it up
in a
way it builds it up
but with the pimp it breaks it down
yeah
is love
just a transaction
where your
s your your attractiveness as a woman is
being traded for a man's ability to
provide
it's not love it's some horny dude
you know
justifying in his mind you know
why he should pay for it because he's
lonely or whatever but is there such a
thing as true love or is it always going
to be just some kind of transaction
i believe in true love i hope i find it
one day i hope somebody just loves me
and it's not transactional i don't have
to pay them
to be around them i don't have to pay
them to be with me
i don't have to pay them for affection
that's ideal but i don't think it'll
happen
i got my sons you know i said i prayed
to god i said oh my gosh i used to pray
all the time and say i just wish i had a
man who would love me
and he gave me three kids
three boys
i should have been more specific right
but yeah i don't that loves stuff
you know it's a fairy tale kind of
but i still hope for it
and i'll pay for it just like these
tricks
what personality traits have helped you
survive and do this
continue
i try to be like a chameleon
i don't even know who i am in a way
but
i try to
i just be what i think people want me to
be
period
i think you want me to be submissive
i'll be submissive if i think you want
me to be
ghetto ratchet
i'ma be like that you know you want me
to be a lady i'll be a lady if you want
me to talk like you know
i know the s.a.t words
i'll go ahead and do that i'll meet you
where you're at
that's that's
one of the toughest things i i've
seen in girls that do this
is that
need to adapt
yeah and work with this guy who's very
dominant and aggressive and this guy
who's very quiet and shy
and then your next guy is something in
the middle and one guy barely speaks
english and you're just jumping from one
relationship to another
and adapting constantly
it's an interesting skill that you're
developing
[Music]
or an interesting mental problem
right
do you get depressed or angry or anxiety
over doing this constantly i'm always
depressed are you yeah it's like i'm
chasing happiness love and happiness
that's what we're all doing though
oh yeah
what do you think the most misunderstood
thing is about girls that do this kind
of work
oh they were dirty
yeah that where
some of them are but
the pros yeah that people think were
like dirty or diseased or something when
really were cleaner than
a woman who you know seen a monogamous
relationship
you get tested for health-wise yeah it's
actually you know
stds and things like that yeah
oh yeah
regularly
every month
you have to make sure but you're but i
don't have unprotected sex you don't no
that was i was gonna ask that i don't do
full sex
gfe
like i'll give you the girlfriend
experience but you know you're not
sticking you're cocking me without a
condom
unless i want your baby
i'm all about a check
let me find the right one
i will poke a hole i'm just joking
i'm not though i would you get those
kind of things happening you get guys
pressuring you to do it without a condom
and
yeah
yeah and those guys you know i think
they're probably diseased
because why would you want that you
don't know me
you don't even know my real name
would you want to stick a raw [ __ ] in me
so they must be you know i don't know i
always think guys like that already have
diseases or they have some kind of
vendetta toward prostitutes they want to
infect us all you know can't do that
can't rock like that it's not worth it
how do you think these years of working
the streets or working as a sex worker
has changed
i've always been doing sex work
since i was a child so
now i just get paid for it yeah it's not
really something new for you it's
actually something you started kind of
at four years old
what was the best time of your life
oh
i had given birth to my son
and i had to have a c-section and it was
super scary but then the best time of my
life
was when they had like lifted him up
and he was looking at me he had both his
eyes open
brand new baby
and he had my face
and i was like oh my god he stole my
face
but he was staring at me and he didn't
take his eyes off me
so that's love
that's
something like that that's love yeah for
sure he's like
with no conditions you
know i love him he loved me so much
yeah that's the best time of my life was
meeting him and seeing like
it was like as soon as i said something
you know i was like oh my god he stole
my face his eyes said boom and jess was
was that your first yeah yeah yeah but
i'm sure you have all three years since
oh yeah in different ways in different
ways yeah but
how's that i can't say i like love one
more than the other yeah just yeah
they're different kids it's all
differently different people
yeah very different people
my first one you know
i just described what that was my middle
child he's so sweet he's such a sweet
little man
and my my baby you know
the little one
huh he's very affectionate he always
gives me little kisses and hugs
they kind of
give me what i need
each of them that i don't get from the
pimp
it's wonderful to hear a girl a woman
who does what you do
speaks so
beautifully about her children
hey everything
you know i made them they're tiny me's
yeah
i might not love myself too much but
i make up for it
loving on them
yeah
those boys
you ever stand back and look at this
lifestyle you're leading and just go man
this is nuts that i'm doing this
sometimes i'd be like right before i go
in especially if it's a new guy even if
it's somebody i've seen plenty of times
i'd just be like damn i hope i don't
[ __ ] die
or i'd be like dang
you know if i die i hope they find my
body
yeah
what do you what do you what have you
learned about men how many of your
clients are married
majority of them majority of them yeah
so what does that tell you about
one time this guy's um his wife came
home you know and i was hiding in the
bathroom you know and i had my gun that
time
and my pimp
i don't know where he was but he
couldn't have came anyway but i had my
gun and i'm hiding in the bathroom and
they're arguing and then she sees me and
she's like trying to attack me and i
take out my gun and i said i just want
to leave
i just want to go let me leave
and they both was froze you know
and i left
i was naked
but i had my [ __ ] and i had my strap
and i left
then i got paid
and you got paid right damn right do you
[ __ ] the money before you start or oh
yeah
don't let them trick you you know
these hoes be stupid you want to get
paid after
get your money up front
it's a trick or trick you and decide how
much you want to pay you no matter what
price you sit
and then what you gonna do
what advice would you give to a young
woman who's considering doing something
like this
i would say
start with the internet go to the strip
club present yourself with class so that
you can earn a higher rate
pursue regulars
sell a fantasy and not
you know
just [ __ ]
and you'll get paid more you make more
money oh yeah
that's my advice
don't have a pimp
because at the end of the day
you know
he can't save your life
what's your biggest regret
my biggest regret
is giving everything away
but
i give it away because i just want some
love
from like a man not like my sons
you know right
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
that you all you got
you came in this world alone
and you don't die alone
whether it's your mother sister cousin
child even ain't nobody gonna give a
[ __ ] about you at the end of the day
ain't nobody gonna die for you
just like can't nobody go pee for you
period
poo
all right luna thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you for having
me very interesting
thank you having that i'm glad we met
too thanks john
you